earlier this week a gunman murdered
eight people
including six asian women in a hate
crime in atlanta
our hearts go out to the families and
communities affected by this violence
no one should have to experience the
pain they are going through and
this event didn't come out of nowhere
how did we get here
let's find out in a segment called how
did we get here
america has a long and well-documented
history of anti-asian racism but
during the coronavirus pandemic violent
attacks against
asian americans have increased by 150
percent
asian americans have reported street
harassment attacks on their elders
and vandalism of their businesses one
[ __ ] in texas
graffitied a ramen shop do you know how
stupid and racist you have to be to get
mad at soup
especially when that soup is delicious
get a grip racists
now it's really impossible trump to say
trump
why something like that trump would
happen but
i do know that anti-asian violence
spiked after trump and other republicans
started referring to the coronavirus as
the china virus and other racist terms
and it doesn't surprise me that this
kind of rhetoric would lead to an
increase in violence
partly because i have the common sense
god gave a housefly and
partly because america has a long
violent history of scapegoating asian
people
which i a comedian will now try to tell
you about in the five minutes i have
between commercials because
the american school system has failed us
all
anti-asian racism in the u.s falls into
a weird duality
on one hand there's the model minority
myth well-off and middle-class asians
are seen as the good successful
minorities
their success is so-called proof that
racism doesn't exist
and that other minorities just aren't
working as hard but also
their success is not fair because
they're keeping good white kids with a b
minus average out of harvard by using
the totally dishonest trick of having
better grades
now it's the dumbest widest thing to
have a theory that proves
your country isn't racist that is
actually a hierarchy of races
obviously not all asian americans are
well off harvard students
and that's where the double-sided trap
of anti-asian racism comes in
on the one hand you've got the model
minority myth and on the other the
yellow peril myth
the myth that asian people are somehow a
threat to the western world
since the first working-class asian
immigrants arrived in the u.s they've
been seen as disposable labor in the
1860s chinese immigrants arrived to
build the transcontinental railroad for
one-third of the pay of white workers
well chinese men did chinese women
weren't allowed to immigrate because
and i wish i was making this up they
didn't want chinese people to fall in
love here get married and stay
what kind of evil empire tries to outlaw
love
that is some darth vader death star [ __ ]
asian workers have been the targets of
violence and lynchings throughout
history
in 1871 during the chinese massacre
10 of la's chinese residents were killed
in 1885 in rock springs wyoming
28 chinese coal miners were murdered and
the city's chinatown was burned down oh
and fun fact at the time it was illegal
for an asian person to testify in court
against a white person
i know that wasn't an actual fun fact
but it's the closest we're gonna get in
this segment
in 1900 one asian person was suspected
of having the plague and
the city of san francisco put up barbed
wire
and literally quarantined the entire
chinese population in chinatown
while in other areas people just burned
chinese neighborhoods down
i told you these facts would not be fun
but they are plentiful
in 1882 the u.s passed the chinese
exclusion act
the first time the country barred people
from immigration based on race
but not the last time because if there's
one thing america loves to do let's keep
people out
we're like the bouncer of countries
during world war ii
the united states imprisoned japanese
people
including children because they thought
they might be loyal to the japanese
government
which is funny because when i think of
groups who aren't loyal to the u.s
government
that's not who i think of what i'm
trying to say is
donald trump is an [ __ ] but he's not
an inventor
he ain't done nothing new he simply
tapped into america's long
violent history of dehumanizing asian
americans now
there's been a lot of talk this week
about what we should all do in the wake
of violence in atlanta but
i'd like to talk for a minute about what
we're not going to do
what we're not going to do is disrespect
the lives that were lost this week by
acting like words don't matter what
we're not gonna do is act like asian
hate doesn't run deep in this country
america does not get to hide from its
racist past or
present and what we're not gonna do is
act like white supremacy
isn't at the root of all this contrary
to everything this country was built on
white men don't get to decide who lives
and who dies
white people don't get to decide our
humanity
dismantling white supremacy starts with
white people admitting they have a big
problem and black people will continue
to stand in solidarity with our asian
family because
white supremacy is killing us all of
us i remember last summer when people
from all over were protesting and saying
protect
black women black lives matter seeing
that felt really great
and i want that feeling for you so just
to be extra explicit
we hate this it's not right your
feelings are valid you deserve to feel
safe you deserve to be safe we love you
this has been how did we get here
[Music]
you